(comical music)
- We've been drinking.
- This is my--
Oh, she knows.
- Fifth or the sixth glass, I guess.
- No, then this is my first.
- Well, I've had two and a half beers.
- Two drinks of rum and half a beer.
Wow, I'm quite sloshed.
- I've lost count, man.
- Let's ask this bottle.
What are you thinking?
- I'm happy high. Tipsy.
- I'm just drunk. I know that.
- Making me smile.
- My senses are heightened.
I think I'll still be like--
- She lies.
It takes me two and half hours to
drape a sari on myself when I'm sober.
- I've never done that in my life.
- I think it's gonna
- No.
- be easy as (beep).
No.
It's not going to be difficult at all.
- I'm so ready to, so ready to--
(laughing)
- We are in a petticoat and a blouse.
- Oh my God.
Oh my God.
- I don't know what to do with this.
- I just like to cover
myself up by this point.
- Ari, this is not the fold.
- Dude, this side is the fold.
Ahhhhh.
- Ah!
- Yeah, tuck in and then tuck it back.
Tuck a little on the side.
Why are you twirling?
- Part of the turn that goes like this.
- I have big hands so I can
make really nice pleats.
- What are pleats?
- What is your opinion on quadratic, uh?
- This is rocket science, man.
Look it! Mean pleats.
- [Yellow Sari] Oh, I did something
really wrong here.
- Did I?
- The sari just keeps riding down
and you keep walking in
gardens with (mumbles) most.
Most...
- Most Indian women wear saris in gardens?
- Most events happen in gardens.
(laughing)
- It was... (laughs)
- Okay, but this isn't
supposed to be... (laughing)
- How 'bout I use my thumb
and you use your fingers.
- Listen, when I'm drunk or something,
I don't have a speed distance time.
- Now we have a sari clad woman.
- Woman!
- Oh, la la!
- Guys, I think I'm not--
- [Gold Sari] What the
fuck? How can you be done?
I'm not done.
- I'll un-trav you!
- Help me.
- [Light Green Sari] As I said
earlier, I'm an expert in--
Wait! You're turning too fast.
- [Yellow Sari] No, wait wait wait.
Can you please not touch
anything and stand straight?
(Gold Sari groaning and laughing)
- It's gonna go...
- Okay.
(finger snapping)
- Here.
(giggling)
- Okay.
- Four pleats.
- Um, five?
- Five pleards, six pleards.
- You know what?
Pleats are spay-see-ark-ula.
(giggling)
- If you move these, these are gonna open.
Don't move.
- To show titty or not to show titty,
- That is the question!
- That is the question.
- This is...
- I'm going to put my
hand inside your pants.
- My-nuh-swee
- Listen, there should be
seven pleats, my mommy told me.
- I am a caterpillar,
- Show yourself.
- who's been cocooned in a sari.
- And once I emerge from the sari,
I will be a piece of (beep).
- Draping a sari is a piece of art.
(Green Sari singing)
(dreamy music)
- Oh wait, (beep) my life.
- I'm awesome, aren't I?
- I'm not.
- Aren't I?
- She is.
- And how do they make
saris flow so gracefully?
I just gotta do it.
- This is how--
- Always be suspicious of
people who get you drunk.
- My dad knows how to drape a sari well.
- And you don't know!
- Because I'm...
Because it's too confusing!
- It's okay.
- I can't even drape
my life around myself.
(beep), I just...
- Shout out to Andy who
made my sari look good
on my Instagram profile picture,
because this shit is "oh my god."
- Usually, when I'm wearing a sari,
I'm very stressed about the
pleats and how perfect they are,
and it should hit the correct corner,
and the line should be straight,
and who gives a (beep)?
Who gives a (beep)?
- How did it--
- It's perfect.